good afternoon everyone and uh Happy uh Friday
welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of
Virginia and I'm very proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series the lecture Series has
been supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences the
school of data science and through grants from the
National Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme has been
data science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where each Friday we've
enjoyed presentations from leading thinkers about
the issues the promise the opportunities and the
hurdles which are associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of the covid-19 virus
these include but are not limited to delayed
Health checkups and treatments mental health
concerns drug abuse increased obesity and the
long lingering health effects associated with
the SARS covid-19 virus participants selected
for our biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will be leveraging these presentations
as vital material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be held at
the lodge at St Edwards Park in beautiful Seattle
Washington in June of 2020 of 2023. today I am
delighted to welcome our final speaker of our
series Dr Vivian bonazzi she chief chief medical
biomedical data scientist and managing director
um at Deloitte Dr bonazzi received a Bachelor
of Science in medical laboratory science from
the University of Canberra in Australia and MSC in
Pharmacology from the University of Melbourne and
a PhD in molecular pharmacology and computational
biology from the University of Melbourne she is a
highly experienced biomedical data scientist
who's always had a passion for understanding
how data science methods and Technologies can
be applied to biomedical data to yield a better
understanding of biology her work is focused on
more easily being able to share access analyze
find and provide attribution to biomedical data
and tools regardless of geographic location
size complexity so as to enable new biomedical
discoveries she is a thought leader concerning
the development of a data Commons a cloud-based
platform supporting the ability to to easily
utilize the fair principles for biomedical data
and tools importantly as a 2023 bdsil Mentor
she recognizes Champions and advocates for team
science approaches for major biomedical research
Endeavors and this is work that she carries on
today working at Deloitte so in bringing to a
close our 2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar Series this spring today's lecture is
entitled towards a data Commons for biomedicine
or the amount of biomedical data continues to
grow at ever faster rates and Vivian will describe
for us some of the community experience the team
science approaches need needed for developing
a data Commons that is this interoperable
infrastructure which co-locates data storage and
compute with common analytic tools and she will
present several case studies and underscore the
importance of Team science in doing data science
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube if you're watching on
YouTube thank you so much for joining us and
for having joined us throughout the year also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and alumni are
strongly encouraged to submit any questions they
have via the chat feature in the zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or
so the lecture and with that welcome Vivian we
are absolutely so pleased that you're able to
join us and share with us uh some of your thoughts
and your work and ideas thank you so much Jack I
really appreciate it I'm looking forward to today
um so today what I'd like to do is follow on off
that wonderful introduction there by Jack but
first I'd like to just give a little bit of an
understanding about what I do and Deloitte and I
hope that also touches on the aspect that I think
Jack's been really talking about which is team
science so as Jack stated before I'm the chief
biomedical data scientist and also a managing
director at Deloitte I co-lead the biomedical data
science group within deloitte's known as BDS and
what we have in my team is a diverse set of Matrix
skills for the various projects that we do and
I've listed some of those out here I have quite
a few folks in my team that are PhD Ms biomedical
scientists of some sort almost everyone in my team
they come from a biomedical background but they
understand about data or metadata they don't
necessarily code but they can and but clearly
they understand the constructs of those data
and also the meaning of that data we also have
data scientists that can also be some of our PhD
scientists but we also have data scientists
that don't necessarily have that background
and I just listed a couple of things that we use
on a regular basis here but the rest of the team
is also made up of important different skills so
Cloud Engineers we have cyber Security Experts we
do UI ux design we also do importantly project
Management's really complicated large projects
require very capable skills in putting things
together these are not simple timelines these
are really complex management plans to ensure
that we can actually meet the deadlines that we
have proposed and work closely with our clients
but we also have to be able to communicate both
with our clients and other people that are
not necessarily in our field so we work with
marketing folks within Deloitte but we also have
science writers within our team and then because
we're dealing with large contracts mostly with
the government which I'll speak about in a minute
we have to work with legal conflicts of interest
deloitte's large so you have to ensure and we do
a lot of auditing so we have to ensure this in
a conflicts of interest we deal with contracts
financials and pricings each one of the people
that represents that skill in my team is Matrix 10
for different parts of a particular project and we
work really hard at trying to make sure that those
overlaps come in at different times and people may
not be skilled in pricing if they're a scientist
but they understand what that needs to bring and
that theme is something I'm going to try and sort
of thread through this that interdisciplinary
nature of the way we do science and the people
is critical for success and being able to drive
the future that we handle with digital ecosystems
the work I primarily do is in the government
and public sector so I work with HHS agencies
primarily I work with NIH and CDC but the rest
of my team and my co-lead Jurgen Klink works
with some of the others listed here we also work
with the VA and also military health and I do
refer amount of work with health non-profits in
my field they're often disease related or organ
related but they're all dealing with very similar
issues that the government is dealing with as well
the work I do is we provide advisory support or
effort if an organization is trying to understand
how to use its data or to develop data governance
uh we also provide analytics services for managing
storing in and primarily interconnecting an
organization's scientific data we can connect
it to its Enterprise data that is not related
to the science we understand the connectivity
pieces in there but we tend to primarily focus on
the science so that's what we do and I'm trying
to make this go forward so what are we going to
talk about today well today we're going to talk
about biomedical data as a key element in these
complex and evolving digital ecosystems I think
all of you know something about biomedical data
by the end of this you'll know more about it but
data in itself does not sit on its own and
I think understanding how it fits into the
ecosystem is important because we often think of
them as individual elements and that can create
its issues also depending on what you come from if
you're a pure biomedical scientist or a pure data
scientist you will see the world in a different
way so when you're looking at an ecosystem we
have to work together both technically but we also
have to work together as people to understand it
I want to point out a couple of things as
I go through it's an evolving pla place
for looking at digital ecosystems and they're
not well connected or interoperable I don't
think that's malicious it's just the nature of a
large collection of data that you need to work on
at times it's difficult to understand where
to start but if you do look at improving
interoperability it improves the ability to share
and reuse data and to further discoveries and I'll
bring up a couple of points here but I think
the obvious one as I think everyone knows with
covid-19 we didn't have a really good way of
sharing our data to start with and it became
really apparent that we needed to do better if we
were going to work together to try and solve how
to treat uh track it Etc and lastly I'm going
to talk about how all of this fits together in
terms of the data Commons and how that can support
data infrastructure interoperability because it's
really these two things data and the the systems
that it sits on that have to work together in
order to be able to drive Discovery and better
understand that data so so I'm not going to talk
about this and the reason why I want to bring
this up is because almost every talk people
ask me what programming language should I learn
it's depending what you need to do so I'm not
going to go through this it is important but it's
a rabbit hole that I don't want to get into today
what I do think is important is these topics
they're equally as important as as that
the skills of writing code are important I
certainly spent many years doing this but it's
understanding the context of what you're trying
to do that's equally as important I can find
many data scientists that can code in python or R
but not that many that understand the context of
what they're writing for and why and if you don't
do that you won't really understand what you're
doing in the first place and secondly you just
create more silos and lack of interconnectivity
so what I think is equally important to draw it
here is when you're looking at ecosystems is you
need to understand the holistic picture of what
you're trying to do scientifically understand
the context of the analysis you're trying to do
you have to understand how to use data securely
particularly when you're looking at biomedical
data because it's it's often controlled access
it deals with human data and authentication
and authorization is important not so much
the application is in the tooling here that I'm
talking about it's just you need to know who's
permitted to use it and who is not particularly
when you're dealing with human data what is the
business value of data I'm going to come to this
again a little later you may not think about this
as an academic institution but it is a business of
data organizations are businesses and if you don't
understand why you're generating that data or how
you're transforming it in some way then you're not
really understanding what real value is going to
be inside an organization whether that be academic
or commercial I think it's really important to
have a set of skills that you can communicate
to non-technical members of your team whether
they be non-scientists non-computer scientists
none of the above that are really working in
the legal application of some of these I've had
many examples uh in working at Deloitte where
I'm working with other team members that have
none of the backgrounds and computer science
or bio but they really need to understand what
we're trying to do to ensure that we really can
deliver and if there are any concerns about that
I think a really important one which is close
to me but I think it's it's something that's
important to increasing number of people's people
is what are you doing to support interoperability
shareability and reuse of your data tools and
your results if all you're doing is something
in a microcosm that may be valuable but I think
if we are able to share our information and our
data that's going to help with new discoveries I
think it's also under important to understand how
to use data responsibly and that really comes
from a diverse set of skills one of the skills
that I haven't listed before was an ethicist but
we are increasingly looking at that because as I
think we've seen recently with AI generating tools
the issue there becomes how are you ethically and
responsibly using some of these tools for the
outcomes and the impact on on on people's lives
particularly when you're talking about health
and you're also dealing with health disparities
so I think really it's very important that when
we bring teams together to solve these problems
they have those diverse skills and they listen
to each other another really important skill
and I think understanding that data is really
part of a complex and evolving digital ecosystem
is important so you can bring your technology
skills to this but you need to be thinking about
these things all the time I urge my team all
the time to be thinking about these kinds of
things that are outside the norm of what they
do on a daily basis because I really think It
ultimately provides the best way of an outcome
from a project and also the best outcome when
difficulties arise within the team to be able
to talk to each other and figure things out
right so I'm going to talk a little bit now around
the data itself so what do I mean by biomedical
Big Data again I'm just going to point out some
things here some of these may be obvious some are
not um dodo comes in various forms in biomedical
data so there's Imaging types of data I've shown
those here there's genomics data which is a really
big it's certainly been over the last 20 years
growing large number data set but also protein
folding protein data is very large spectro data
is pretty huge uh electronic health records which
were usually all written on paper and now almost
all electronic and they're increasing in number of
volume and there's always wearables which I think
most of you will have come across as well and that
the volume of that data is really huge so it's a
large set of data we're talking about so what does
it really when I say what does it make it big well
it's volume there's a lot of it in terms of size
velocity the rate of which it's coming out is very
high and it's getting faster the variety which
is many different data types there are increasing
number of data types and subtypes as time goes on
and veracity which is this lovely term applying
to really you know what's the quality of
that data and if we don't pay attention to
any of these things then we're not going to
understand how to deal with the data itself
but all of these things together are
important but what's it really pointing
to and I think the key thing here is that
we're in a digital economy and that data
itself has value and that that data is
actually Central to that digital economy
in particular here I think I want to point
out that a digital economy is characterized
by using data to gain a business advantage and
as I mentioned before I said the word business
yes academic institutions are a business and
I think you have to think about that for how
you're thinking about what your digital economy
is in whatever organization you are and that the
organizations of the future have to be born
digital if you don't you you'll really be at
a disadvantage I think this new economy is really
important to think about it as a digital economy
so I think in the future and now I think true
organizations will be defined by their digital
assets and how they will be leveraged so in
scientific organizations uh scientific digital
asset I'll use the term data uh throughout the
rest of this talk but I really mean any digital
asset and that could be data and metadata coming
from a specific experiment that you wrote down
and digitized or it came straight off a machine
it could be analysis that you've done uh that
you've taken data from a machine it could be
the metadata that you've taken from that data
that came from machine or was transformed but
it also applies to artifacts like software the
analytics the workflows any services like apis
you have with it that is also a digital asset
the documentation which is really important the
uh the Sops the readme's anything else that you
have Journal articles and increasingly
in the digital world blogs blogs YouTube
Etc I think we're talking about
that today this is being streamed
I think what we're trying to get at here is that
the most successful organization organizations of
the future will be those that can really leverage
their digital assets and transform those into an
interconnected digital ecosystem if you just have
lots of digital assets and you can't connect them
they're just dots in the system really is
that transformational knowledge will come
from understanding the interconnectedness of
that digital ecosystem foreign so let's look
at some of the issues around biomedical data
there are many and it's what's stopping some of
that interconnectivity but there is some hope and
I'll bring that a little bit later in this talk
so I think in the case of certainly in the
academic world the journal article is still often
seen as the end goal that means that the data that
supports that General article is a means to an end
and it's low value and I think some of that is the
lack of incentives around this and that is funding
agencies in general have prioritized by medical
outcomes and consider interoperability a secondary
interest so essentially publish your paper doesn't
matter about the data it's okay you needed to use
it for the paper but then we're done and that data
is not is not fair this is a term that is being
used increasingly uh both in the commercial and
the academic world and that is relating to data's
findable accessible interoperable and reproducible
when you pay attention to this this really allows
connectivity within data now I have a short
hopefully it'll show up this is a two-minute
video some folks may have seen this before I think
a couple of thoughts here is this is the issue
of what happens with data when you pay attention
only to the journal article the other interesting
thing about this little video is that if it will
play is that this was done in 2012 and really the
issues haven't changed that much so I'm just
going to play it now and hopefully it will run
hi hello my name is Dr Judy benign I'm an
oncologist at NYU School of Medicine hello
Dr Judy benign I read your article about
B cell functions it was very interesting
I think that I could use the data
for my work on pancreatic cancer
I am not an oncologist I know but I think I could
use the data for my work on pancreatic cancer
oh so do you have the data everything you
need to know is in the article no what I
need is the data will you share your data I am
not sure that will be possible but your work is
in PubMed Central and was funded by NIH that
is true um it was published in science which
requires that you share your data I did publish
and science then I am requesting your data
can I have a copy of your data everything
you need to know is in the article
no
I am not sure where my data is but
surely you saved your data I did I
saved it on a USB drive where is
the USB drive it is in the Box
it is in the box at home I just moved
but can I use your data
there are many boxes well
I forgot to label the boxes
all right so I think now we see this is
a problem that is consistent uh and we
still can see it being a problem at the
moment uh there's a reference here um
down the bottom here if you have the slides
you can actually watch the entirety uh of
this YouTube video it's actually quite
long I just took a small slice of it
but you can see that the shareability of data is
a problem when you only look at Journal articles
so some additional considerations around the
problems with biomedical data data is cheap to
generate and costly to store in local servers
that has been problem for quite a long time
um lately what's been going on certainly over the
last uh several years now it's cheaper to store on
cloud in the case of biomedicine gcp Google or AWS
are the primary stores but that's changing as well
but they're the primary ones at the moment you
also have issues where you get multiple copies of
the same data in different locations and sometimes
on the same Cloud so you can have five copies of
the data they're all in gcp but they're all in
separate accounts and no one is able to share the
data or wants to there's also a case of building
data resources that cannot be easily found by
others and that data resources are not connected
to each other and cannot share data or tools
and the focus of late has been to build on cloud
platforms and tools and really it's all about the
tool not the data when you do this and you
have these kinds of issues it creates silos
and it creates difficulty in using the data
even just for a small number of experiments
and most researchers really want to be able to
share data to have new discoveries and to share
it in order to find out different things
from their own data or other people's data
but when the incentives are unaligned this is what
you get so what's changing though I think there's
a number of things that are actually occurring at
the moment and they're all in the positive realm
so number one research repositories for data are
increasing where there's a requirement for when
you store the data there's some consistency in the
way you store it rather than just being stored at
a pi site the other one is the landmark paper
around Fair which I think came out in 2016 by
Wilkinson I've just got a copy up here this
is really pushing the idea of that findable
accessible interoperable reproducibility of data
and guiding ideas and policies where it's really
driving that kind of adoption is really important
additional to that in underlying pieces is
increased use of metadata and consistency in that
metadata having unique identifiers associated with
data that are not driven just by one organization
but an agreed-upon set of identifiers open sharing
and open data standards and software okay
I think that's also driving that you can
adopt New pieces at fonts like Lego blocks if you
they're all the same and you can re-share these
NIH data sharing policies have been evolving
as well I've worked at NIH but I've also been
consuming of some of their data and support some
of their projects as of 2023 they and at the
bottom here is the link for the URL NIH released
the 2023 data management and sharing policies
which are substantial and they are really moving
towards fairness of data and I think that's really
driving it from a funding and a policy perspective
and requiring groups to spend more time to think
about those things and then there are examples
of a Community Driven organizations I've given
one example here which is the Global Alliance for
Global health genomics and Global Health which is
ga4gh but there are others like RDA the research
data Alliance and many others that are open
standards for using data and tools and Adoption
of those results in a consistent use of data and
also systems that actually support it so I think
there's a lot of supporting this in the community
and I think there's a lot of drive to do a better
job of that I think the fair principles here drive
data to become the currency of an organization and
make it reusable and much more easily shareable
as a resource and the policies that promote
that data sharing via VIA Fair help change the
culture inside an organization whatever that is
to ensure that you can create connectivity of data
okay so let's move on we've talked a lot about
data but there's more to it than that and that
is we also need to think about a digital ecosystem
that allows transactions to occur on Fair data at
scale and that's pretty common biomedicine
because the data is large and diverse we're
talking petabytes and above and you need to be
able to do that you're not going to be doing
that any on anything except some sort of computer
and the concept of a data Commons which has come
from a number of people is really about looking
at digital assets and infrastructures including
software and all the other pieces that support use
of data and making them fair so can you reuse apis
that have a consistent form is your data in a
form that's consistent with some sort of data
standard that's what we're getting at when you do
those transactions at scale with data that's and
digital assets and infrastructures that are fair
that allows to look at interoperability so a data
Commons facilitates data and infrastructure
interoperability and a data Commons can be a
cloud platform but often isn't and I'm going to
talk a little bit about that but first before we
go there what do I mean by a data Commons this is
just really a principle here it's really in three
parts there's some form of compute it's usually
Cloud but not always you can have on-prem or and
there are also hybrids there's a data layer
of some sort and then there's a collection
of tools and services and they range in a couple
of different types at the lowest layer there are
services that basically interconnect with the data
in some way move it around they're not related to
any of the science but they prepare the data in
some way to be able to make it used it's also
important to have an authentication layer there in
order to be particularly if it's protector data in
the case if you're dealing with NIH data dbgap is
one of those controlled Access Data you want to
ensure that that data is truly secure in allowing
access to only people that are authorized to use
it but you also need services to index data to be
able to run containers and workflows and then you
have over the top of that tools that actually do
the analysis in a scientific form and not everyone
in the biomedical world is able to code and so
what we need is user interfaces and portals that
allow scientists without that kind of background
to be able to interact with the data in a useful
meaningful way and they can do experiments so
really that the layer of a Commons is in three
parts the compute platform which is usually cloud
data and some form of software services and tools
that interact with the data but as I mentioned
before what you wanted those tools and data to
be is to be fair to apply and to comply the best
possible standards that are available at the
moment so when you're comparing two things with
a software or data these things are interoperable
and so I've got a little icon here down in the
corner it's really a little platform if you
want to use it that that uses Fair principles
and I'm going to use that diagram and again
so moving on let's talk about some of the
challenges that we have with data commons's
I think we have a number of these and if I can
get my slide to go all right so the last five
years we've seen a huge explosion of academic and
Commercial Cloud platforms and quite a number of
them claim to be data Commons it's but there are
differences that difference is is merging which
is good but there are differences so collab
platform looks like a data Commons and it's
basically Cloud Plus data plus tools but the data
Commons is really trying to apply that fairness
which is what are you doing with consistency
of using data standards or best practices to
your data and your software in that system so
that when you're going to work with another
system it's using the same principles the
problem we have is that cloud platforms look
like a Commons but they're not they tend
to be mostly driven as an internal source
so let me describe a little more of what I mean
by this Cloud platforms really are built with a
premise of simplifying data and often a slick
UI they're optimized essentially for a very
specific purpose and often a very specific data
type or data types a small number of data the
reason for that is they're trying to look at a
series of use cases for some sort of scientific
use case and they have two three five maybe data
sets which they bring in-house so they store the
data on cloud specifically for this particular
thing the datron tools are fair enough within
the confines of the specific Cloud platform what
happens inside those is these Cloud platforms
often have project-based data schemas they're not
necessarily compliant with the current standards
and they're not necessarily using utilizing
any Fair terms or any other assets whether it
be software or data within the platform and what
happens over time with these platforms too is the
data schemas and then conformed entirely for the
platform and they evolve away if they started from
a standard they evolve away from it simply because
they have an internal Focus to drive to an outcome
um it is also true that some of these standards
are not available at the time so they have to
create something but what happens is you get an
insularity in terms of the data schema specific
for that cloud platform and that causes problems
if you're trying to get one Cloud platform to talk
to another one they also prioritize internal
capabilities over external connections that
support interoperability by that I mean
they prioritize the kind of software they
do to drive to what their outcome is so in this
case and I point this out here in the incentives
often these Cloud platforms are driven to some
sort of biomedical outcome by the definition of
some use cases they have when you do that you
build all of the software and all of the data
that comes to that is aligned with whatever
that outcome is it is not aligned with being
necessarily interoperable that is not the
first thing that is thought about here and
as time goes on you that becomes more and more
complex and it becomes more and more insular to
the actual Cloud plot from itself this is what
I mean by prioritizing internal capabilities
rather than trying to externalize Via interoper
interoperability the incentives are not aligned
either it is not to and the incentives are not
to interconnect with other Cloud platforms the
funding agencies really prioritize biomedical
outcomes and they really often have considered
interoperability a second interest if you spend a
lot of time doing interoperability and you don't
look at the outcome and you have a funding stream
from NIH and they're looking for an outcome this
causes a clash so people will naturally just
build a system that will go for that outcome
the commercial clouds are really not that
different in this context and that is the
commercial Cloud platforms must maintain market
share and drive sales to their platforms so the
more users they have that are willing to pay for
their platform they're going to keep modifying
that so it's really easy for the user to keep
coming back and using whatever their platform
is there is no incentive here for commercial
platforms to interconnect with others because
they would simply lose market share and this
is just created a great deal of essentially
vendor lock-in whether you be academic or
commercial and they become essentially silos
but there are some issues here to be fair to
the cloud platforms that I think points to this
issue that ecosystems really are evolving and
that is theory is as a term and application is
extremely complex and very time consuming to
achieve effectively I don't think we haven't
achieved an optimal yet I think we're still
trying to work it through because we understand
that the shareability of data and the ReUse of
it is important for cost and also for achieving
discoveries Fair itself is an evolving landscape
for example there's an increasing number of data
and Tool standards and best practices they're
changing they're being upgraded updated every day
and new ones are coming out as we have new types
of data new types of Standards around software are
coming out as well before it was just a tool now
there's consistency around the workflows because
often when you're doing biomedical studies
you're looking at collections of data and
collection of workflows because it's a collection
of tools that you're using to do the analysis
and I think interoperability is a particularly
complex and thorny issue it's complex to do it's
uh doesn't immediately seem to be of much benefit
and if you have to drive to an outcome and that's
where your funding is coming from you're not
going to spend time doing interoperability
so I think that cloud platforms have
really proliferated proliferated here
because academic funding agencies and I
think commercial companies do prioritize
the immediate outcomes over interconnectivity
and reusive data and I think we have to come
to a balance here and I think we've got there
yet because if you just do interconnectivity
and reuse of data without an outcome why are you
doing it on the other hand if you're just doing
an outcome and you're building it on use cases
those are fairly brittle and you're only going
to build a system that handles three or four
of them so this balance is where there's a lot
of discussion at the moment in the community and
understanding where that sits is very important
so back to team science a little bit here this is
where a matrixed team that has different skills
can understand these balances you may be coming
from a software engineering perspective you may
be coming from a biology perspective you may be
coming from an outcome perspective where you don't
know anything about tools and I think having
those voices heard and being able to listen to
each other will drive to a balance between these
two things the outcome and the interconnectivity
so some additional things here to think about
about what's changing and things that are I
think improving this so the picture at the top
of this is kind of pointing to this which is
left picture there at the top is what I
described as Cloud platforms that don't
have fairness and then data Commons is that do
I think you're getting a blending of those two
because there's an understanding that there's
value to do that it's not perfect but I think
it's starting to happen a lot more and I
think there's a number of reasons for that
so there's increasing examples of value of sharing
data effectively it's become really important I
raised this at the beginning of this talk covert
19. that was pretty clear fairly early on that we
had an inability to know where the data was be
able to share it and to be able to do something
with it so where were the cases where were they
happening what was the level of spread who was
dying who was getting sick what was comorbidities
all of that kind of pieces of information were in
different silos across the country and I think
a network of people that had interdisciplinary
skills uh really cried to look at this to try
and solve that problem and I think this isn't
one example of a number that is showing that
when you can share your data effectively you
can get to good outcomes quickly but you need to
think about that interconnectivity in order to
be able to do that or you're spending an awful
lot of time data cleaning and data wrangling
I think organizations are recognizing the value of
consistent and shareable data they're realizing or
the example I gave above about covert that when
you do that it gives you a valuable outcome but
you have to spend a little time up front to clean
your data and spend time to make it interoperable
and aligned with Fair principles I think funding
agencies are proactively supporting data sharing
policies and open data tool and standards for
example as I mentioned before nih's new 2023 data
sharing policies are really quite deep and complex
and I really applaud them for starting to think
through the implications of that they're much
more aligned with fear than I think any previous
policies and I think having funding agencies lead
from that perspective it's going to drive all of
that work within uh grants and contracts that
the NIH is running but that's also going to be
true across all of HHS agencies I think also
adoption and also promotion in the sense of
support for not promoting individually open data
and Tool standards I think is really important
they're asking people not to recreate the wheel
and develop your own data schema or tool or data
format but to reuse what's out there already and
to participate in those Community Driven standards
I think cloud vendors are creating consistent
services that work across clouds early on the
vendors were very specific to their own clouds and
they did not want to have inter-cloud connectivity
you can run Services now between clouds and
similar Services run on each Cloud that makes it
a lot more consistent if you're doing that kind of
work microservices this is another element where
there I think of these as small functions often
apis that Loosely couple together to accomplish
our complex task so they're not some monolithic
system they're little collections of services
that can do something individually that you can
connect together like Lego blocks and I think
there's uh there's certainly growth in this area
for a number of different groups that are building
commonses that are using microservices as these
functions to couple together things rather than
to build monolithic systems and it allows
connectivity by those apis to other systems
I think there's further development and improved
adoption of the Community Driven standards and
software standards and integration of those into
Cloud platforms depositing data in software and
open repositories this includes GitHub but there
are also collections repositories I know that NIH
is looking to reuse and to deposit data that's
coming out from pis into current repositories
that they already support I think another element
here that's really important is Citation of data
and that is in journal articles in the past
citation has not been present there's been
no way to do that that's been changing over
time if you can cite your data in tools and
also show where you've deposited it and that's a
requirement in papers in journal articles I think
that will be incredibly important for the ReUse
of data and tools it makes a lot easier to find
and actually to reuse if they're following Fair
principles I think another key one is improved
education of data and infrastructure issues
by organizational organizations leaderships
often what I found is the leadership c-suite
in commercial organizations but leadership in
government organizations they're often not
that well versed in data or I.T or systems
or infrastructure or they're only inversed in
one and they're asking their teams within their
organization to help them understand what they
need to do but they themselves are not very well
educated in that so what you will end up getting
is a lack of understanding what really needs to
get done they'll drive it to just outcomes and
they won't think about this interconnectivity and
why that's valuable so if we improve the education
of the organizational leadership I think this will
help it's a great deal in overcoming some of
these problems I think the last one here is
really important and it touches on what I think
Jack has been trying to drive out with this series
is the use of interdisciplinary teams if I take
it back to what I just said about organizational
leadership if you have interdisciplinary teams
that work together if the scientists understand
what the computer scientists are doing with the
computer scientists understand the science the
biomedical science if you have ethicists working
with you if you have people with different skills
that come together to deliver on a project and
there's an equalness about their skills it will
help Drive organizations in terms of using their
data per se those people will lead those parts
of the conversation but those people in those
interdisciplinary teams I think will also rise to
leadership positions with organizations and that
will change the cultural organizations over time
so I think it's these Collective things that
we're starting to see that I think is going to
change the landscape of the way that we handle
ecosystems and we drive to interconnectivity in
a way that's meaningful for the community useful
that it still gets to outcomes and is supported in
the incentives aligned whether you work for
Academia or industry to get to that outcome
right um getting to just my last slide here
I'd like to thank a number of people here um
particularly Jack and his team thank you for the
opportunity to speak today and this great idea of
um the workshop I'm really looking forward
to going to that I'd also like to thank Dean
fullborn at UVA he and I worked at NIH together
but also we've been working at UVA and he and I
are very interested in data commonsers and have
been speaking about this for many years and also
especially thank you to Dr Nathan Sheffield
Nathan wrote a paper recently with some of
the information I provided here is discussed
he's discussed it in way more detail and the
premise of the talk is really strongly about how
microservices could be one solution to looking at
Fair data and Analysis and I've just included the
reference here and DOI I'd also like to thank Dr
Jurgen Klink who's my co-lead for the Deloitte
biomedical data science team my entire Deloitte
BDS team who I learned from every single day and
I realize what I don't know they're a young group
of incredibly enthusiastic fun people to work
with that really do espouse interdisciplinary
approaches and each day I realize my own blindness
so I think that team a great deal for pointing out
things that I need to learn and I'd also lastly
like to thank many NIH colleagues who I worked
with previously I spent over a decade at NIH and
there are many people at NIH who really diligently
support Fair best practices they really care about
it and they have a very strong understanding of it
and they come from very strong biomedical and also
compute science backgrounds and I'm really pleased
to see that NIH is making quite big strides in
this area and it has some fantastic people that
work there that can really take them to the next
next step right I think that's my last slide Jax
so back to you thank you Vivian that was wonderful
and you will certainly find a Ally in me about
the the strengths and importance of having a team
science approach in this business biomedicine is
hard enough um you know by yourself just to keep
up just to be able to understand all that's going
on and so you really need to have smart people
working in those domain areas where you can turn
to them and have them you know basically just
uncover your blindness rights of what you're
you need to know about I was impressed when you
were talking about um organizations being born
digital and they'll be defined by their data
assets can you say a little more about that
yeah let me get back to that slide so I
can remind myself what you were saying
there or myself you were saying yeah I was
saying so you're talking about this one
I'm not seeing your slides at the moment sorry uh
I'm sure it's the same one yeah this is a digital
economy as characters by using data to gain
a business and manage that much yeah that's
the one yeah so what I mean by that is I think
if organizations don't so if I get this right
organizations that are not born digital will be
at a disadvantage what I mean by that is I think
organizations need to understand that they have
a lot of digital assets and they need to figure
out how to leverage those in order to really be
a player in the digital economy so universities
traditionally have you know there's a lot of data
from experiments but it's written in a notebook
so there are now electronic notebooks but
how do you share those electronic notebooks
um it's thinking about everything that you've got
digitally and ensuring that it is digital so that
you can take most advantage of the data you have
that could be scientific data but it could also
be Enterprise data like student data information
about how many students attended class you don't
take role by paper anymore you do it digitally I
think these kinds of things give us insights of
data at scale and we need to think about that
broadly across an organization so I think it
really takes that mindset of thinking digitally
from the outset that's what I mean by born digital
that you really are doing it from the outset uh
and thinking about that because I think that's
going to give you the greatest understanding
of your own data and interconnectivity
I certainly think that as we are collecting
more and more data through you know advances
in the various technologies that you
know are in Laboratories now or that uh
just thinking of like cell sorters and various
other things that are helping us to uh collect
data ever faster Gene sequencers MRI scanners
that data is being born digitally it used to
involve you know somebody you know doing a lot
of hard work to you know get the data into a
form which would probably pop out in a
in a spreadsheet and now it's you know
gigabytes and terabytes worth of information it's
itself is born digitally and so by thinking from
the get-go about those as digital assets that are
themselves born digital and you are creating an
organization or kind of pivoting your organization
to being more digital is is important and I was
thinking that um this is probably important
as people are entering the field and things
like the NIH strides program are becoming uh
something we need to attend to and I don't
know that you mentioned it specifically but I'm
curious if you might share what you know about it
I do know about it but that's mostly because I
used to deal with it from the inside of NIH but I
also have the great Fortune of working with it now
as part of Deloitte so which part of it would be
the most valuable to you to tell you what it is
or how something else well what it is what it's
aspirations are and what its current status
might be if you know sure so first of all
I can't represent NIH but this is just my
understanding of it so strives was born as a
way to be able to provide NIH with access to Cloud
because what had happened over time is researchers
had been using primarily AWS but some gcp but not
under the auspices of NIH and the problem becomes
particularly cost because academic institutions
and academics can't afford the commercial prices
and it doesn't make sense at scale so if you're
using part of your Grant to pay for cloud and
you're paying commercial costs and you're doing
it multiple times it just didn't seem like an
economy of scale and also it made sense since the
world is digitally born right as you pointed out
quite rightly Jack things coming off machines are
born digital yep Cloud was going to be used more
and more so NIH needed to develop some sort of
relationship in an appropriate way with the cloud
providers that was the driving force behind it and
then what strides was was to set up an agreement
with Cloud providers it started with gcp and
AWS I believe it's moved to Azure now where the
concept behind it is that there's a reduced price
for use of compute storage and services the idea
behind it is that it allows researchers to get
a better price on that and it's also allowing
NIH to to work better with Cloud providers to
understand what services they do provide and
how they can be better used for science that's
essentially what it does and it's complicated
to get that done within a government organization
but I think they're making great strides no pun
intended in terms of actually leveraging that
so that's currently what I know about stones
what uh you you talked a little bit about some of
the work that you've done um with Nathan Sheffield
who's a faculty member here at UVA the stuff that
you've done on microservices or at least looking
at them as a possible solution um do you feel
that microservices are something that's you know
instead of crafting one big giant all singing
all dancing solution is that if microservices
themselves were granular enough that people could
kind of create their own workflows through data
in a much more Nimble fashion is that one of the
ideals behind the microservices movement yeah and
I I urge people to go read the paper I think he's
done a really nice job of that yes I think the
idea behind it and what he uses in the paper is
the concept of Linux right oh well Unix right you
can run individual service that in itself is very
minor but coupled together with a bunch of things
you can come up with a very complex workflow and
they're all in the same system using the same kind
of methodologies and that's the idea also you can
mix and match you may not need every single thing
in a monolithic system so that those microservices
are a way to Loosely couple things together to
accomplish a complex process it does still
require you to have a Computing background but
it's not requiring you to be part of a monolithic
service and I certainly know of people that only
want to live the World by microservices and not
monolithic Cloud platforms but I think there's
probably a happy balance between those since not
all scientists can code or know how to use an API
what does um the what do microservices
and sort of the you know cobbling together
your own workflows which is not a bad
thing um but out of microservices what
does that say about data provenance and
reproducibility of processing well a lot
um I mean if you have a set of services that
are operating on Fair data then and you also
track the provenance I think that's a
good thing to try and do at all times
um because you'll understand what you
started with and where you came to an end
so I think that's a really important
aspect of the way that it would handle it
and also the consistency in the handoff between
those Services if the services themselves are fair
and I think that that's really critical
in terms of doing that they could also
depending on how you set them up not handle
data provenance they could actually end up
turning this around if they're not connected well
together and lead to more problems but I think
that's the nature of where we're at I don't
think serve microservices are the only solution
or the solution I think as I'm saying my
last slide they're one of a collection of
things that we have to try out and then think
about the actual data we're feeding into them
to in order to understand the implications
and impacts of them including on Providence
I want to thank you for sharing your your thoughts
I completely agree about the role of Team science
and why that's important do you think that there
has been a cultural shift towards this notion of
Team science here and I mean since more and more
data and organizations are being born digital we
sort of need to become you know more attuned to
what's going on in fields that are adjacent to us
in contrast to being these like hyper-specialized
people you know that only really focus on our own
thing it's is there an increased awareness of
the need for data science or sorry team science
as we're performing the data science that's
needed to understand these complex data sets
it depends it depends on the organizations I've
certainly seen organizations uh academic and
commercial that see the value of it they realize
that bringing interdisciplinary teams together
helps figure out what problem they really have
and what they're going to tackle in what time
frame and why I think that's that's certainly true
but I've definitely seen organizations which are
driven by pure science that pay no attention to
the complexities of the software engineering or
even project management they're treated as
plumbers and when that happens you tend to
drive to use case driven systems I think of those
as brittle use cases because you build a system
that will handle three use cases and it won't do a
fourth one at all and the software engineering and
the project management are aligned just with
delivering that but if if it's driven from a
science perspective without understanding of these
other complexities of software engineering and pmo
project management you get to these brittle
use cases I think it's also disrespectful to
the team's skills not everyone in the team needs
to have a PhD or an MS right it depends what your
skill is I have many people my team that don't
have they have an undergraduate degree in whatever
they're very skilled at project management they're
certified as pmps and they are equally as valuable
as someone who has a PHD or an MS in bioscience
so I think it depends on the organizations I
think we've got a way to go I think commercial
organizations are understanding that to drive to
an outcome um I'll talk about an Informer and when
you're driving to drug outcomes you know in terms
of new drugs on the market you need to be able to
drive larger data through cloud and you need to be
able to work in an interdisciplinary team so that
you can get it speeds up what you're trying to do
they can really help I think interdisciplinary
teams can help speed the to outcome to get to
more reasonable outcomes that are useful in
a broader sense probably Drive costs down if
they really work effectively together and I think
one of the most underrated skills is listening if
you've got people with different skills in your
team they're not going to be an engineer then
they're going to need to understand
the engineer is going to have to be
able to understand how to speak in a language
that's translatable to the person that isn't
so we have plenty of people in my team that are
explaining the science to the data scientist about
why you need to use that R code or that python
whatever to do to take an outcome this is what
the science we're trying to do so let's apply the
right code and they're sharing information all the
time it helps our data scientists who don't have
coding experience understand the complexities of
coding and the coders understanding why they're
actually doing what they're doing what sort of
advice might you have for data scientists um kind
of learning about Commons and Cloud architectures
um who are maybe working in disciplinary teams
with say biologists what sort of things might
they need to know as they enter into those
relationships and organizations listening
is the most important skill um realizing that you
don't know everything that your world is not their
world and trying to understand what it is they're
trying to achieve respect for each one's skills
a higher degree does not mean that you have
more skill over someone else it's the multitude
of skills that come together [Music] um I think
the soft skills are really important in terms of
team science they're often underrated but for
a team to really work together it's those soft
skills it's often not the hard skills they
have them it's how you bring them together
it's the sharp edges what do you do when you get
to a disagreement or you don't understand those
are the pieces that you need to bring together
and you need to pay attention to it so almost
you need to leave your coding skills at the door
and start being a human with another human trying
to figure out how it works and once you do that
then you can bring the skills to the table often
not the other way around isn't it interesting that
after all of this technology all of this Advanced
Computing sophisticated Computing languages
and dealing with terabytes terabytes of data
it comes down to a human human interaction that
is really the end result of all of this uh it's
kind of interesting coming for you know in a
full circle like that I I agree I think it's
it's the human interactions because I mean we ask
computers to do things we make data Fair because
we want to learn something from it but it's it's
really us as humans getting together to understand
and those are just tools whether it's a data
Commons data fairness software you name it those
are tools to help us understand what we're trying
to do but it really comes down to communication
between us in terms of understanding what are
we trying to get done here with the set of tools
that we need to accomplish that it's a really
tough one I often think about this and think
you can you can say what you want to code it's
not going to fight back unless you change some
line of code but if you don't have a pleasant
conversation with another human being it can
result in a not a pleasant outcome and you project
can tank maybe because of bad relationships it's
very important I think to have those soft skills
so that you can find the ways to Quirk with people
that aren't in your field and then bring the
tools to the table not the other way around
Vivian thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts with us and providing us with a
lot of insights into the role of Team science
into all this complex Cloud infrastructure that
we're certainly uh if we're if you're
not familiar with it you soon will be
um but it's really important at the end of the
day it's people who are interested in this we're
always interested in machine learning I think
people learning still has a role in all of this
um I want to conclude our biomedical data science
seminar series for uh this particular theme uh on
secondary health effects of covet 19. um I want
to thank Gina camdar and Hannah kears for being
my helpers to make all of this work so smoothly
um they're the ones responsible for organizing
all of these speakers and for promoting things on
social media and so none of this would be possible
without them we are really looking forward to
meeting with all of our biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants in person in Seattle
Washington here in a little more than a month
I think having Vivian there is going to be very
exciting we have other NIH program officials who
are going to be joining us as well as a slate of
really engaged and enthusiastic mentors so we're
really looking forward to that and I just want
to thank everybody who's joined us over the last
several months to thank you so much for doing
so so I hope you've learned something and we
will look forward to seeing you all again in the
fall when we start up with whatever our next theme
is going to be we haven't yet decided yet but we
will but in the meantime everyone have a wonderful
Cinco de Mayo for those of you who observe and I
have a wonderful Friday and a great weekend and